[Music]
something
weird is going on the days are
getting longer the weather is getting
worse and
a lot of surfers look sad
chin up guys maybe the waves will show
up tomorrow
while it may look like we have a full
moon up there
what if the other half broke off
are we doomed
what causes moonquakes
what would happen if half of our moon
drifted away
and has the moon already split in half
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if you cut the moon in half
as friendly neighbors in the sky the
moon
and earth have a symbiotic relationship
the moon's gravity keeps us on a fixed
schedule
creating tides that travel around the
earth every 24 hours
since the moon is tidally locked to the
earth
we always see the same side of the moon
so if we lost the dark side
we might not notice immediately but
would the other half start to drift away
if the two halves can escape each
other's gravity
over millions and possibly billions of
years
the moon chunks would become spherical
again
sculpted over time by gravity the earth
could be left with two smaller moons
making star wars fans everywhere rejoice
even if the moon were cut in half we
would only notice a difference if
one piece disappeared if the moon were
half its size we'd experience only
partial solar eclipses known as annular
eclipses
with less mass the moon would start to
venture
closer to earth so even though it would
be smaller in size
it might look bigger to us and
with weaker moon gravity our tides would
be smaller
affecting underwater ecosystems living
in the intertidal zone
the area between high and low tide sea
turtles
seabirds and fish would be endangered
knowing when to feed lay eggs or migrate
would be incredibly difficult
without the regularity of the tides
the presence of the moon also slows down
the earth's rotation this keeps our days
24 hours long with only half a moon
there would be less drag on earth
leading to 15 hour days
if you're working the night shift i'm
sorry but prepare for a pay cut
with less stability from the moon's
gravity
the earth's axial tilt would change
causing dramatic seasonal shifts and
swings in temperature
this is why mars has such crazy weather
its two tiny moons make mars
wobble on its axis causing dramatic
changes in temperature
and high winds
uh houston
we have a problem there's something
wrong with the moon
it seems to be missing a chunk and well
i'm really curious about it
copy that peter we're sending you a
briefing now
all systems go initiating curiosity
stream
whoa cool thanks houston
no problemo peter we've got you covered
if you're eager to learn more about the
moon or space
curiosity stream offers thousands of
documentaries and non-fiction titles
from some of the world's best filmmakers
including exclusive originals
there's truly something for everyone
with topics covering science
nature history technology lifestyle and
more whether you like to learn on the go
or kick back and relax curiosity stream
supports
many different platforms and is
available worldwide
as a subscription-based service you can
get unlimited access
starting at just 299 a month or 19.99 a
year
to help you get started on your learning
journey go to curiositystream.com
what if for unlimited access to the
world's top documentaries
enter the promo code what if to get it
completely free
for the first 30 days so
how exactly could the moon split in half
well like earth the moon has several
active faults called thrust faults
over millions of years the moon has
cooled down
from a hot melted rock to what we have
today
this cooling has caused the moon to
shrink
in a process known as thermal
contraction
the moon has gotten about 50 meters
skinnier
over the last several hundred million
years
hey moon looking good nice and trim
thanks peter as the moon shrinks
its volume decreases and compresses the
surface
like a grape turning into a raisin the
moon
wrinkles as it shrinks causing its crust
to shift
and trigger intense moonquakes some of
them
are quite strong around five on the
richter scale
a moonquake would have to be pretty
severe to cut the moon in half
but an asteroid impact in the right spot
could do the trick although it wouldn't
be a clean cut
and would likely shatter the moon into
several pieces
some historians have come to the
conclusion that the moon
may have cracked in the past on june
18th
in the year 1178 several people in
southern england
reported seeing a raging fire spread
like a snake on the moon
astronomers think that what these
villagers saw
could have been the three kilometer
asteroid that formed
giordano bruno's crater this would have
triggered the expulsion of a
massive amount of lunar material about
10 million
tons in the direction of earth talk
about an
epic meteor shower now
while the moon won't likely split in
half anytime
soon it is moving away from us
at a speed of 3.78 centimeters per year
that may not seem like much it's not
going to make the moon
appear any smaller but with many
potential moon mining projects in the
works
our moon could look very different in
the future
so i guess enjoy it while it lasts
[Music]
if you think losing half of the moon is
scary
well what if there was no moon at all
could we survive on a moonless earth
well that's a story for another
what if